ich tauche nie mit Welt vor junge
unheilbar kranker Mann das ist Mona
mittendrin
[Musik]
hallo hallo
also normalerweise drunter
[Musik]
Menschen mit der Muskelkrankheit
erste Folge zeigen sich häufig im
Kindergartenalter zum Bewegen
alle anderen im Körper laut
die durchschnittliche Lebenserwartung
jetzt bin ich am Handy
[Musik]
wie ist das für dich
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
bis zum Programmieren von Webseite
der Manuel ad da sind News bildet zu
Media Markt
40% schaffte im Moment als Texter was
machst du
findest das macht mir wirklich Spaß oder
ist da einfach machen
[Musik]
wir müssen zwischen zum Teil muss ich
mir das Timing
auftauchen
oder
okay ja
[Musik]
für mich
das Wasser springst Wasser leben könnte
[Musik]
also das Spiel findest du auch gut
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner und die
Mitarbeitenden
[Musik]
jeden Tag hat sie eine eigene Strategie
mit dem schicksalonska Manuel helfen vom
Buddhismus und Meditation
[Musik]
das
was ist das für euch hallo das ist
macht nichts
was erzählen okay
Tag und Nacht sind die pflegen
[Musik]
allein zu am Morgen aus dem betrogen
braucht's
[Musik]
für die jüngere Bewohnerinnen und
Bewohner starteten Tag mit
Schulunterricht
[Musik]
sagt man Sonnenwind aber der Wind heißt
auch hier Sonnenwind
der Mittag begleitet Brian 16
dann können
schönes Wochenende tschüss
so selbstbestimmt wie möglich sie das
ist Ziel der Manuel ist einer von der
wenigen ist
ich glaube seit lange
super
lecker
das ganze
ja genau
unbedingt
ja in der Wege von der jüngeren sind
robusten Schuhe
ich
tschüss
so groß wie Vorteile
einfach so
man ist das
Stadion beim FC Zürich
für 320 als mediamatika
mal zwei Jahre und Nacht dann weiß wie
kann ich meine
Plattform
Computer okay und ihre interessiere mich
für alles was mit Technik das du hat
okay was weißt
die laufen beim Fußballen okay wirklich
vor
Fußballer
was um Traumberuf sie und jetzt
super und jetzt können wir was gemacht
okay
[Musik]
ganz genau
Instagram Bekanntschaft
und die anderen was machen die
[Musik]
wie viel können sie überhaupt erleben
von dem wo man so macht wenn man jung
und gesund ist
[Musik]
im Rollstuhl
das ist sehr schön viel wert Möglichkeit
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sehr viel bedient
[Musik]
alle Möglichkeiten aus
Information
und das finde ich schon faszinierend
also dieser Fall wäre da noch extra
[Musik]
Manuel gitze bis wo du selber sagst das
werde ich noch machen da versuche oder
das ziehen
ist
das für dich
sozusagen
weniger Behinderung
[Musik]